this week marks the official start of
the fall movie season among the movies
audiences are looking forward to is an
adaptation of Stephen King's it
superheroes will come together on the
screen and Justice League and George
Clooney will show off his work behind
the camera with suburbicon Erik Davis is
the managing editor at Fandango and he
joins us here could morning good to see
you
all right we've been talking about it
all night it yes you think this is it it
is you know I was shocked at how great
this movie is I'm not a big horror fan
I'm not a big Stephen King guy but this
film just has this great throwback
sensibility it's super scary it's funny
it's romantic it feels like something we
would have gotten in the 80s maybe even
from somebody like Steven Spielberg the
kids are all great you know and in this
era where shows like stranger things on
Netflix are causing a lot of waves this
movie really kind of fits in with that I
think and so if you're a fan of that I
think you what's it what's it rated it's
rated R yeah and you know yeah a couple
you know a couple of years ago this
would have been pg-13 but now studios
are leaning into the re a little bit
more well they're seeing success you
know we started seeing with comedies a
few years back the hangover bridesmaids
then we start with the superhero movies
Deadpool Logan now the horror movies you
know right now I feel like we're seeing
some of the best horror movies ever made
are being made right now leaning into
the r-rating really helps it and I think
it's gonna help it at the box you're
scared to go see this book was
incredibly scary and I I'm suspecting
that this is yeah based on the trailer
it is you know 27 years ago is when the
miniseries came out 27 years in the book
is how long it takes between it comes
back a lot of movies were talking about
here based on true stories yes coming up
here right goodbye Christopher Robin
Molly's game yes this is one of the
trends for fall yeah usually a big trend
in fall mollies game starring Jessica
Chastain this is from writer director
Aaron Sorkin this is Aaron Sorkin's
directorial debut in my opinion one of
the great writers of our time based on a
real story of Molly bloom aka the poker
princess if you remember her from a
while back she was an olympic-class
skier who got injured and then became
like embroiled in to the heist
underground poker scene with celebrities
and you know Jessica Chastain is so
great at playing these high-powered
independent powerful woman who know what
they want know how to get it
pairing her with Aaron Sorkin's dialogue
is like a match made in cinematic heaven
really looking forward to that excuse
the pun I'm going all-in on that
Christopher goodbye were robbing the
real story of Winnie the Pooh how Winnie
the Pooh came together which is a
fascinating story takes place post-world
War One about the fractured relationship
between a father and a son that little
boy of course the real-life inspiration
of Christopher Robin so complicated
history for Pooh Bear and her friends
yeah but definitely want to check out so
George Clooney reuniting with the Coen
brothers every time they get together
they make incredible films what are you
expecting this time yeah this is George
Clooney back his director Matt Damon
Julianne Moore Oscar Isaac star this is
actually based on a Coen Brothers script
from the 1980s believe it or not also
loosely based on a real-life story that
took place in suburbia Levittown
Pennsylvania 1957 about a model suburban
community that rided when a black family
moved in so this is where this film kind
of takes place in this world just
premiered at the Venice Film Festival
George Clooney says it was an angry film
for an angry country a lot of buzz for
Blade Runner 20s that's nerd out over
Blade Runner and superhero movies we've
got Thor coming out Justice League and
what do you think well you know Blade
Runner 2049 I'm hoping for a sci-fi
masterpiece personally you know the
director I think is one of the most
exciting directors right now a guy by
the name of Denis within the wavelength
he directed last year's arrival as well
as Sicario Harrison Ford Ryan Gosling
Jared Leto looks visually amazing thor
ragnarok this is the third Thor movie
look for a colorful Thor funnier Thor
guy by the name Tyco a TD directed it he
made one of my favorite movies of the
last few years what we do in the shadows
so look for Mark Ruffalo's hole Cate
Blanchet is the villain in Thor so
that's exciting and then Justice League
it's like DC's Avengers this is all of
them in one film Superman Batman but are
you hearing that it's going to be good
I'm hearing that you're now going black
I know you're absolutely right it's
still going no wonder woman is in a
Calvados wonder what massive hot summer
I think that that's the draw in my
opinion that's the line I use from Jules
in Pulp Fiction I'm going no I'm going
Davis thank you my friend as always